hey youtubers it's Charlie so Zack
Snyder dropping some new stuff from
justice league and we learned some stuff
about the Aquaman movie so this is gonna
be a breakdown so if you guys haven't
been seeing it they've been posting a
bunch of Justice League stuff lately
they're still filming justice league so
this picture of jason momoa in his full
Aquaman armor is from the set of Justice League
him playing some underwater
stairway to heaven,
so we've seen him in the trailer
we learned a little bit
about his character and he's like a
complete 180 from real-life jason momoa
jason momoa is like one of the most
charismatic people that works on justice
Lee but you see here getting ready to
bite Henry Cavill is the most adorable
thing ever
please put jason momoa in all the films
in the good thing I think about him and
justice League is that he's gonna balance
Ben Affleck's Batman out like you want
to have a version of Batman that is
hardcore but they can also be funny
so you kind of need someone else to be
even more hardcore than him so that is
where Jason Momoa Aquaman comes in but
they've been working on the Aquaman
movie in the big news now in like part
of the whole reason for making this
video is that they've been out Black
Manta will be the main villain which
isn't so much of a surprise I mean he's
like the reverse-flash of the Aquaman
comics like his greatest nemesis that
always comes back even if he's not in
every single story so what I think we'll
see you know in keeping with tradition
because Justice Society has all the
Justice League characters in it and then
some of them will go after their
spin-off films after that like Aquaman
they will tease some characters that are
going to be in the Aquaman movie during
Justice League Black Manta being one of
them even though the timeline they push
the story forward just a little bit if
they're getting their first felt like
when the flash gets his first film even
though we know the origin of the flash
even already has his tech suit they have
to at least touch on the origin story so
that means that injustice llegan in
present-day Aquaman will already have
this lifelong vendetta with Black Manta
but they will explain why in the Aquaman
movie so if you haven't read a lot of
Aquaman comics you don't know their
backstory together basically it's like a
you killed my father prepare to die kind
of situation very princess bride but we
know one of the funny things in this
happens with a lot of comic book
characters is that they've read con that
story like the story between them that
Feud several times because black mantas
original origin story is just way more
hardcore like a little too hardcore for
modern audiences like there was this
story like when he initially debuted in the
comics where he got captured put on this
fishing vessel made to work was sexually
abused by his captors and that is just
like the most dark thing ever and you
have to imagine that a bunch of kids are
gonna be going to see this movie so
they're like okay yeah we're probably
not going to do that in the movie so
later runs of the Aquaman comic have
read con black mantas backstory to make
it a little more mythological a little
friendlier to especially younger
audiences so the most recent version of
black mantas origin story is the
princess bride new 52 origin story where
Black Manta kills Aquaman's father then
vice versa
Aquaman accidentally kills black mantas
father in retaliation for that but that
wasn't his intention he wasn't trying to
revenge kill black mantas father but you
get the idea
you killed my father prepare to die so
lifelong feud very easy to follow
meanwhile Aquaman is super-powerful
Black Manta just has a lot of really
high-tech gear and super-strength that's
really about the limit of his powers but
here's where it gets a little bit of fun
black man of course Aquaman always ends
up defeating black manta, black manta
lands some pretty big wins like there was
a win where he actually got Aquaman's
trident but there was a period of time
when he joined the Suicide Squad Amanda
Waller like visits black manta and
prison is like
here's your armor if you join The
Suicide Squad will give you your life
back
so the interesting thought about this is
you know I don't think the black mantas
going to be in a Suicide Squad movie
anytime soon but think about this once
they get a couple of these big justice
league spin-off films out you build a
roster of villains like you have
villains in the Wonder Woman movie
you have villains in the Aquaman movie, you
have villains in the Flash movie
they could eventually be used in a future
Suicide Squad movie like think about it this way
Lex Luthor could be part of a
Suicide Squad movie in the future
if he's still in prison so here's my big
question for you do you want to see some
of the big villains from the spin-off
films you know from like the solo films
show up in Suicide Squad after they've
been defeated by each hero just remember
that they will cycle the makeup of the
actual suicide squad depending on the
type of story that they want to tell I
think there were a couple of characters
that got shoehorned into Suicide Squad
this time but that doesn't mean that
future Suicide Squad sequels won't be
able to do like other really
cool characters that you've seen in
movies already so let me know which
other villains, like do you want to see
the reverse-flash and lex luthor inside
the Suicide Squad Black Manta even king
shark, king shark is like a smaller
character that was in the Suicide Squad
before that they opted not to do,
just because they wanted an actor with
practical effects in king shark would
have been a full CG character but he
actually looks really badass in the
flash TV show but speaking of other big
comic book characters so they announced
like Miss Martian Mon El a couple big
characters for Supergirl season two
there's some justice society legends of
tomorrow stuff that I need to talk about
so i'll be doing videos for that next
but if there's any other comic book
videos that you guys want me to do this
weekend
just let me know in the comments there's
still a bunch of Marvel stuff i know we
were talking about a lot of Star Wars
last night so we got a bunch of Star
Wars got a bunch of DC got a bunch of
Marvel stuff in expect to see more from
the set of Justice League zack snyder
just keeps like teasing stuff out like
here's aquaman with the guitar in his
full armor happy friday and
congratulations to this week's DC
giveaway winner Mongol you can use it to
help fund your quest to rebuild Warworld
maybe we'll see you on Supergirl season
to eventually just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact details i'll just
start a new round of the giveaway when i
post that Supergirl season 2 video so
that will be up later tonight while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for that Justice League
trailer again and you can click here to
learn all about the flash season 3 they
just announce who the black flash is
going to be thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five i'll see you
guys tonight